hello i'm caleb dawson a post-doc
in the breast cancer lab of jane
visvader and jeff
linderman at the voltron eliza hall
institute
of medical research in melbourne
australia
i just finished my phd where i was
working on
breast stem cells and immune cells using
3d confocal imaging and intravital
imaging
so today i'll talk to you about how
these lead to new insights
into resident macrophages of the mammary
gland
please get in touch by instagram or
twitter
so you can ask questions and we can and
we can discuss this
the mammary gland is a really dynamic
organ that remodels
a lot over the life of a
female mammal so i'll introduce you to
this and then i'll introduce macrophages
as well
these are really diverse immune cells
that have very specific functions in
every organ
then i'll show you how we made a really
interesting
observation using 3d confocal imaging of
mammary ducts
spying these new immune cells
and then go through how we characterized
these
and found that they were a macrophage
population
and then i'll go into some studies in
breast remodeling and cancer to see what
these cells
do the mammary gland
is a really fascinating organ because it
primarily develops
after birth this diagram shows
the development of the mouse memory land
at birth there is just a small ductile
tree and this doesn't grow
a lot until the beginning of puberty at
three weeks
when terminal end buds form at the ends
of the dots and these house
proliferative
stem cells which drive duct growth and
branching throughout a fat fat
and this generates an elaborate ductile
tree
in pregnancy this tree blooms to
generate spherical alveoli which produce
milk
and after lactation in a process called
involution
these milk producing cells die and a
shed
and this returns the gland back to its
resting ductal state
so our lab we use 3d imaging
to image the different stages of memory
gland development
and we use whole mouth imaging of clear
tissue
and this shows us the shape and the
architecture of the tissue
as well as individual cells where they
are and how they interact
the mammary ducts are made up of an
epithelial bilayer
with outer layer of myoepithelial cells
that are contractile and elongated and
an inner layer of
luminal cells which mature in lactation
to produce milk and with the 3d imaging
we can get a big picture of the stroma
that surrounds the dust
as well as the epithelial cells and any
cells that we interact with
we use a clearing agent called fungi
that was developed
by a previous postdoc in the lab named
ann rioff
and this was published last year
tissue resonant macrophages are a really
interesting immune population
they're really abundant in all tissues
and they develop
from monocytes under the action of the
csf1 growth factor
macrophages typically express f480 cd64
and mert
k and we use those markers to isolate
them
traditionally macrophages are split into
m1 or pro-inflammatory macrophages
and m2 or anti-inflammatory macrophages
from fairly typical inflammatory or
anti-inflammatory signals
but this is a little bit simplistic and
applies mostly to in vitro pathogenic
situations
whereas under homeostatic situations
a vast variety of factors programs
resonant macrophages
into a really diverse range of
phenotypes and functions depending on
the tissue
and the tissue niche but some universal
functions of macrophages
are in tissue maintenance and repair
phagocytosis of
pathogens and apoptotic cells and
regulation of
immune responses
and here are just some examples in
different organs
we have individual or even multiple
macrophage populations each with
very specific functions for that organ
some of the macrophages
have a lifespan of the life of an animal
whereas others survive only for days
whereas others for months
different populations of macrophages
have different origins
they're first generated in the embryo
from the exact and the fetal liver
which seed all organs in these first
waves
and in organs like the brain which
develops the blood brain barrier
after these embryonic macrophages seed
the brain
they are not replaced and they survive
throughout the life of the animal
other populations however lose their
embryonic macrophages over time
and they are replaced by bone marrow
derived macrophages in the al
such as the in the intestine
it's not really clear yet what the
differences are functionally between
aldol and embryonic derived macrophages
so what do macrophages do in the memory
plan
well in puberty as these ducts grow and
branch throughout the
mammary fat pad the macrophages are
required for this growth
in branching and they sit within the
terminal and buds where they clear away
the apoptotic cells
we know that antigen presentation
negatively regulates
this growth but it's not clear whether
this is
macrophages in the adult
macrophages promote mammary stem cell
activity
and they closely interact with the
epithelium and there are some
persistent embryonic macrophages in the
gland
in reproduction they regulate
alveogenesis during pregnancy
and are really important for the
remodeling that happens
in involution
but we really don't know much about the
heterogeneity
of macrophages in the breast tissue yet
and we don't know by which mechanisms
they carry out these functions
so the reason i'm telling you this is
that early in my phd i was looking for
different types of cells that interact
with the mammary ducts
and one of these was immune cells so
this is a 3d confocal image with the
mammary duct here and immune cells in
yellow
and looking at an optical section you
can see
this immune cell stain within the duct
and looking at a thicker section they
start to take form
as the dendritic shaped cells that are
within the epithelium
looking closer with more specific stains
for each of the epithelial layers
shows that these immune cells are
sandwiched between
the two layers of the epithelial bilayer
so here's the myoepithelium and here's
the luminal layer with the
lumen of the ductier and the breast
stroma up here
and we were able to look at different
markers for these cells because they
have such a
specific localization and so here is the
csf1r very typically expressed by
macrophages
which is positive in these cells and
then positive for cd11c
as well and negative for cd11b as this
lets
us hone down on these cells and try to
figure out how we might be able to
isolate them and these markers are
actually quite unusual for a macrophage
population
because most macrophages are cd11b
positive and ct11c
negative
doing some rendering in mrs using the
opaque signal
and cutting off digitally the front half
of the duct
we can see these cells create a network
underneath the outer layer of the
epithelium
and when we imagine lactation we can see
these cells
still and they interact really closely
with the
myofascial cells which are stained with
a keratin 5 or keratin 14.
and these myoepithelial cells wrap
around the alveoli and contract to
squeeze out the milk
they also seem to be present in human
breast tissue
we have these cells just underneath the
outer layer of
the duct
other people have spotted
intraepithelial immune cells in the
breast before
here are some uh and some with
cd11c and then others more recently
associated with the myoepithelial cells
and the epithelium
and then here macrophages underneath the
outer layer
but it hasn't been shown whether these
cells
are a distinct population and whether
they might have important functions
and so using the information that we got
by
imaging we were able to translate this
into facts
so we isolate macrophages from the
mammary gland
and then the macrophages split really
nicely into these
cd11b positive and cd11c positive
population
and so we thought that these could be
these ductal macrophages
or dms and
matching the imaging they're mhc2 high
and lysic c low
and so we labeled these ones the stromal
macrophages or sn's
and these ones the ductal macrophages
but to confirm that these were the
associated macrophages
i did facts of whole glands this is the
frequency of the dust microfibers and
also of
fat pads which had cleared epithelium
so they have no ducts left and there are
no
duffel macrophages and when we do an
enrichment for ducks
we get into the enrichment of these
macrophages so we know now
that these macrophages the cd11c
positive cd11 below
are very specific to the dots and
they're not present in the stroma
we also found that they are really high
for cx3cl1
whereas the strangle macrophages are
lower for cs3co1
and this is just a marker of some
macrophage populations
but the reporter mice help us to get a
really clear picture of
where they are and what they look like
this is looking at the outer layer of
the dust
with the myopathial cells labeled with
keratin fiber
and this obscures the ductal macrophage
network
whereas looking at the inside of the
duct this network is
revealed with the cxcco1 and then
removing the outer layer of the
epithelium completely you can see all
these cells so they're really really
frequent across the whole gland
so we look at the nipple area the mid
distal and in lactation
and they have a really similar
distribution across all of these areas
we really wanted to know what the
dynamics of this interaction were
how do the ductal macrophages move and
how do they interact
with the epithelium and to do this i
developed an intravital
imaging technique using a skin flap so
we
expose the mammary gland and we can
image for up to 12 hours
we have access to an entire memory lane
which is really important because
most of it is embedded in fat tissue
which is really hard to image through
and so having access to the entire gland
uh
helps to isolate ducts which don't have
much fat on top
and to get really nice resolution
and so this is a movie intravital movie
of the duct
which expresses gfp in purple and then
we have an mhc2 antibody
fluorescently conjugated and we
digitally
isolate the ductal microphoto signal
on the ducts using surface rendering and
masking
and this showed that the dms don't
migrate around the ducts
but they have dendrites that they move
back and forth
to survey the diet
and i quantified this by tracking the
cell body
of the dr microphotos and their
dendrites
and also the stromal immune cells
showing that they don't migrate but
move their dendrites back and forth
and then looking at how they cover the
duct at any one time they have about 30
percent
coverage of the duct but through
dendrite movement
we can watch the cumulative signal how
it covers the duct
and this coverage increases really
rapidly in just a few hours
so it looks like these doctor
macrophages can contact
almost all epithelial cells in the whole
memory gland
within every few hours
so are these cells long-lived resonant
macrophages
and to answer this question we use bone
marrow chimeras
and this is where we irradiate a mouse
to deplete this bone marrow and then
inject gfp positive bone marrow
and we shield the mammary glands
to prevent them from being damaged
and then we can look at contribution of
the gfp positive bone marrow cells
to different populations so monocytes
are really rapidly replenished
and so we normalize these to 100
replacement
neutrophils as well are rapidly
replenished
so they match the monocytes whereas the
macrophages in the mammary gland
are slowly replaced so these are long
lived
and so they have a lower rate of
replacement by gfp positive bone marrow
and they have different levels different
rates of replacement
uh but the adoptal macrophages have a
half-life of about
five months so they are long-lived
resident macrophages
but are they initially derived from
embryonic development or do they come
later during adult development
and to do this we used a tool called the
ms4a3
lineage tracing and this was published
last year
and it is a really great tool uh because
linux tracing and macrophages used to be
quite difficult um but this mass
using ms403 td tomato lineage tracing
labels all adult bone marrow drive
macrocharges
because it's active in the progenitor of
the adult macrophages but not the
embryonic macrophages
so what you see here is that at birth
there are no macrophages labeled because
they're all embryonic
then during growth
populations such as microglia which are
embryonic for life
are not contributed to at all by adult
bone marrow macrophages
whereas other populations such as
the colon and the small intestine are
quickly replaced by adult macrophages as
the mysql
and so when we looked at the frequency
of the mass providers in early
mammary gland development this is during
puberty here from four to six weeks
you get a really rapid increase in
industrial macrophages
whereas the other populations are more
steady in this time
and then looking at these my switch
tracks
the adult macrophages before puberty
only a few of them are adult derived so
most of them are embryonic
but then during this ductile growth an
increase in numbers in dms
they're coming in from the bone marrow
and then this stabilizes more as they
grow older
so initially ductile macrophages are
embryonic but and
as the guts grow and branch during
puberty
they come in from the bone marrow
and then to get more of an idea of
what these cells might be doing we did
rna sequencing
and this showed using this mds plot here
that the duster microphotos are really
different
from the other myeloid cells in the
mammary gland
and they have a signature of phagocytic
enzymes and also when we compare the
doctor microphotos to the other
macrophages
we brought out this not signaling
signature which is interesting because
it has been implicated in
mammary gland macrophages before and
also stem cell regulation
and to test this we
had a not reporter master this is a
notch target
gene uh with the gfp downstream
and it's only active during
active notch signaling and this was
specifically
on in the adaptable microfibers but not
the other
immune cells
and so to look at whether not signaling
was important we
looked at cv11c cree rbpj
flock slice and this
knocks out rbpj which is a
an effector transcription factor of not
signaling
specifically industrial macrophages
and when we did this it didn't actually
decrease their number significantly
but rather than being cd11b low
they remain cd11b high so we think that
notch might be important for the
maturation of ductal microphotos
and it doesn't really affect their
localization they're still within the
epithelium
to see what they might be doing during
remodeling of the mammary gland
i did facts across all of these time
points through pregnancy
lactation and involution and found that
this
really striking increase in doctor
microphones into involution
where they really dominate the immune
landscape
this uh increase is driven in part by
proliferation of the microphotos within
the epithelium
not neurons coming in
and so to ask why there might be so many
of them here
i did imaging to see where they were and
they're
on the outside of the alveolar in
lactation and these are the milk
producing cells here
but at four days in volusion as the milk
producing cells are dying
and the alveoli collapse the ductile
macrophages infiltrate
into the lumen and they surround the
dying cells
so it looks like they might be vegas for
toasting these and clearing them away
to get a clearer picture of this i
looked a bit earlier before
the alveoli had collapsed
and here the milk producing cells
expressed the gfp in purple
and looking closer
you can see that these milk producing
cells which have a
slightly dimmer gfp because they're
dying
are being engulfed by the doppler
macrophages with the mhc2 signal here
and really interestingly the milk
producing cells are binucleated so they
have these two really distinct
nuclei of per cell and within the
duplicate microphotos you can see these
two nuclei and see that these milk
producing cells are being phagocytes
but is this important are the doctor
microphones necessary for this
remodeling
and to answer this we depleted them
using the diphtheria toxin model
so if you express the seriotoxin
receptor
in specific cells you can administer
diphtheria toxin
and this will bind to this receptor and
kill just those cells
and so we treated cd11c dtr
mice with the serotoxin upon weaning and
then collected them during involution
and in the control mice we have this
infiltration of the dms
and phagocytosis of the dying cells
whereas when we deplete
we have no dms and we have no
phagocytosis
of the dying cells
during evolution the lumen collapse and
the alveoli collapse
to allow remodeling to the normal ducts
and this occurs normally in the controls
but when we deplete the dms we get a
failure of the lumen to collapse and so
this remodeling is really badly affected
and this is really important for
uh later pregnancies
and has implications for
cancer as well
so through this discovery we've really
nailed down a population that is
important for
this remodeling during evolution but
there are a lot of other
areas that macrophages are important for
in mammary gland development that
still need further investigation as to
which populations are important and
what what mechanisms
now switching tact a bit into breast
disease
in breast cancer breast macrophages
or tumor associated macrophages
are different to the normal macrophages
so in the normal breast we have the c11b
positive cells and as tumors progress
they get more and more of these cd11b
low
tams
so this study separated them into
mammary tissue macrophages
and tumor-associated macrophages which
has this really interesting
phenotype and so
this really picked our interest because
the breast tams
are proteomergenic they're not dependent
and they can proliferate
and so all these features seem really
similar to the ductal macrophages
so we took our rna-seq and then compared
it to rna-seq of the
tumor macrophages and the genes that
were up
in the tumor associated macrophages and
the doctor macrophages correlate
really strongly whereas the genes up in
the stromal macrophages correlate
with the mammary tissue macrophages
and then when we look by flow cytometry
we can see the duster macrophages
here the cd11c positive lysose low
during tumor genesis as the cancer grows
we get enrichment for these cells and
for the more they mirror the morphology
and positioning of the doctor
microphotos in the normal duct
within the cancer
so to summarize the mammary gland has a
population of
unique resident macrophages that monitor
the epithelium
they're bone marrow derived during
puberty but before that
they are embryonic derived they
promote epithelial remodeling by
clearing away the
dyeing milk producing cells during
involution
and they're really similar to breast
tumor macrophages
and we hope that this discovery will
help us to understand
better tumor macrophages
and help us to modulate those to improve
cancer treatment
and so these dr macrophages they have a
unique
markers compared to the strabal
macrophages and they have this
intraepithelial localization
during pregnancy they proliferate to
increase in number
so they cover the whole gland and all of
the alveoli in lactation
and then in involution they infiltrate
the lumen and clear away these
dying milk producing cells and then in
tumor genesis in breast cancer they
maintain this positioning
throughout the cancer
so i'd like to thank now uh especially
my
supervisors jane viveda and rios and
jeff linderman everyone else who was
involved
in this paper in the lab bupinda
francois
um gordon smythe and luke gandolfo did
the bioinformatics analysis
uh felicity jacklin and everyone else in
the lab and the
division i'd like to thank the imaging
facility
animal and facts facilities at the
welterweight hall institute
at the doherty institute especially
scott mueller who helped with the
intravital imaging
with the project collaborators at a star
in singapore for the ms4a3 experiments
tissue joiners and funding
and here's jane and anne with their 3d
glasses because i do want to
quickly show you some cool things you
can do with
imarus with this 3d visualization that
not a lot of people have seen
and i'd be happy to chat about this with
people
and you can check out some of these 3d
visualizations here to look at with the
cyan red 3d glasses
and that's it thank you very much for
watching and
hope to connect with you in the real
world